في اليوم الوطني لمحاربه الغطرسه العالميه
الذي اقرته طهران مسيرات شعبيه برعايه
السلطات الرسميه في ايران يحييون ذكر
لاستيلاء على السفاره الامريكيه في طهران
عام
1979 فيما تحاول الجمهوريه الاسلاميه منذ
ذلك الحين اخماد احتجاجات تجتاح جميع
انحاء البلاد وتدعو الى اسقاطها يلقي وزير
الخارجيه الايراني امير عبد اللهيان
باللوم على الولايات المتحده شجع البيت
الابيض بشكل متزايد العنفه والارهاب خلال
اعمال الشغب الاخيره في ايران بينما يحاول
التوصل الى اتفاقناوي
توقف عن تصرفاتك المنافقه
تصريحات وزير الخارجيه الايراني جاء تردد
على تعهد الرئيس الامريكي جوبايدان بتحرير
ايران
سيحررون انفسهم قريبا
لم يتاخر الرئيس ابراهيم الرئيسي في
مهاجمه نظيره الامريكيه
يقول للرئيس الامريكي تم تحريره ايران قبل
43 عاما
الايرانيه ان رجل امن من قوات التعبئه قتل
خلال مظاهرات في محافظه جيران شمال شرقي
البلاد واوضحت الوكاله ان متظاهرين عنصر
الامن في مدينه
في البلاد منذ وفاه الشابه الكرديه مهس
امين اثناء احتجازها لدى شرطه الاخلاق